To get a better sense of how timing works, I've defined a procedure "spinloop."
Spinloop starts by initializing the variable i to zero, and then it goes through a loop n times.
Each time through a loop it just adds 1 to i.
That will run for longer.
By picking the value of n, we can make it go through the loop any number of times.
Let's try that.
We'll try running the loop a thousand times.
Now, we get no result and the time it took is 0.0001 seconds--about a 10th of a millisecond.
Let's try it with a larger number of executions.
Now, I'm going to increase the number of iterations by 10.
The value of n is multiplied by 10.
If we see that now the time is higher. The time is increased to about 6/10 of a millisecond.
We can keep increasing the time.
Let's try looping 100,000 times, and we see the time increases.
The time increased by about a factor of 10 between looping 10,000 times and looping 100,000 times.
We'll try one more time. Let's go for 1 million.
If we go for 1 million times, now we're up to 0.05--
5/100 of a second or 55 milliseconds to loop 1 million times. Still pretty fast.
We're going through that loop 1 million times. It's still much less than a second.
What's important is we can see that the time changes depending on the input.
As we increase the input to spinloop, the time increases accordingly.